and we're joined now by one of miss
truss's predecessors as foreign
secretary david miliband who's now
president chief executive of the
international rescue committee and uh
good to talk to you uh david um
well selling kidneys and selling
children
one million children in
at risk of starvation it just seems to
get ever more desperate
it certainly is desperate
mark but it's not inevitable there are 2
000 staff of my own organization the
international rescue committee working
across afghanistan
and we can confirm just how desperate
the situation is the reports of child
early child marriage forced child
marriage are part of this story but it's
vital that your viewers understand that
this is not just an aid problem there is
an aid problem in that there's not
enough aid
but if anything the bigger problem is
that the economy has been frozen
since the withdrawal of military troops
from the u.s and the uk and elsewhere in
august there's no private sector at the
moment there's no proper banking system
and there's no functioning method of
paying salaries to public servants
teachers
nurses water engineers and so this is an
engineered crisis
as a result of international economic
policy not just aid policy
because of that it's actually soluble
and we need the british government the
american government others in positions
of power yes to increase their aid but
i'm also here to tell you that unless
you can get the economy functioning by
releasing assets to give liquidity to
the banking system by ensuring that
public servants are paid through the
world bank we're not going to be able to
avoid this crisis which is so bad that
more afghans are now at risk of dying
from malnutrition than died in 20 years
of war but but as you say
you know the truth is the west has
allowed this to happen in
i was seeing figures today that the un
is forecasting a 20 contraction in gdp
in afghanistan by the end of this year
during
syria's civil war that took five years
to happen i mean this is an economic
collapse
of startling proportions that the west
is allowing to happen
well i would say that it's an economic
strangulation mark and if i tell you
that 40 percent of the economy was made
up in development assistance that's
salaries for teachers nurses etc and
that that has ended you can see
quite what a tourniquet has been applied
to the afghan economy we as aid
providers those 2000 irc staff that i
referred to
it's like they're running up an
escalator but the escalator is going
down an economic escalator is going down
much faster than they can run up and
this is the result of policy we need the
british representatives at the world
bank to be saying spend the 1.2 billion
dollars of the afghan reconstruction
trust fund that you're sitting on spend
it now on paying salaries we need the
british representative at the imf to be
saying look we have to address this
frozen assets issue because there's no
liquidity for this import dependent
economy to buy food fuel and medicines
we need yes the un appeal for aid to be
met too and that's a responsibility of
the us uk
et cetera we've got to address this
otherwise it's not just afghans who are
going to be left
in starvation it's europe that will face
a migration crisis and the west that
will face an intolerable stain on its
reputation but this all requires
david western governments and those
organizations you've just mentioned to
effectively you know hold their noses
and release these funds to the taliban
to stage off this
to you know
massive humanitarian disaster
but let me correct you if i may on one
thing uh mark yeah paying a nurse
in herat is not paying the taliban
paying a teacher in mazari sharif is not
paying but how do you do how do you how
do you set that up that process without
involving the regime which whether you
like it or not is running the country
well already the world bank is allowing
those staff who are employed by ngos to
be paid in health centers but we also we
know that more than half of the
country's civil servants are teachers
but paying them
through international institutions
including
world bank or un institutions has been
done in other places for example in
yemen it's been done in part in
afghanistan but needs to be scaled up
dramatically paying public servants
doesn't mean paying the people who are
running their departments it means
getting money into the hands of people
in need also
releasing the banking system allows
afghans private afghanistan's private
sector
to function so this is a really
fundamental choice if you believe that
keeping people alive
is not worth it not you if the
authorities believe keeping people alive
is not worth it that is not just a a a
story about their morality it's also a
story about their inability to
distinguish between punishing a
government they disagree with and
punishing people who've done right well
exactly but it just seems to some i'm
sure hypocritical certainly to the
afghans to rattle for the west to rattle
their charity tins with one hand and
then impose sanctions and block funds
with the other hand
totally and it's also stupid frankly
it's not just hypocritical it's stupid
because the worse the economy is the
more aid they need
and afghanistan is going to have an
economic contraction as a result of the
end of the war economy
and of all that goes with it but there's
a difference between an economic
adjustment over time
and an economic strangulation what you
called an economic collapse in the space
of months remember it's only four months
since british troops left afghanistan
and we know from experience that you can
get money into the right
places what we've got to have though is
the will to see it through and we're
putting pressure here in the u.s the u.s
government has already done some
carve-outs for humanitarian
organizations from the sanctions regime
but it doesn't go anywhere near far
enough and we spent 20 years in
afghanistan you can argue about that you
can argue about the withdrawal but the
people who you've just featured in alex
crawford's unbelievable film in some
ways
they're not they're no one's enemy
they're people to whom promises were
made and those promises have to be
fulfilled if we're to hold our heads up
okay uh well look we've got 20 seconds
left the next few months
you know
winter and all that what is the prospect
if we don't get money and aid in there
now
we haven't got months
mark i'm on this as a matter of days
right we've waited for months and we've
seen the results a million kids are the
risk of starvation according to the
united nations we've got days to sort
this out okay and it is sortable that's
the biggest message i can give you
there's no excuse because this is
sortable all right david miliband thank
you very much indeed
thank you very much